that first of all congratulations uh
that was a very shaky game uh that was
the French okay you still continue
winning games with the French uh tell us
a bit about your opening uh Choice uh
and the middle game of this game and how
you recovered from that difficult
opening
phase Oh I thought you were going to ask
me how I recovered from yesterday
because I was really upset after
yesterday's game too yeah she played the
advance French I wasn't expecting it she
usually plays night C3 so I played a
line I don't normally play with this F6
and we got into some unknown territory
and I don't think I okay I know I didn't
handle it well as I actually checked the
game
quickly after C4 I spent a lot of time
and I guess I didn't react well but I
feel like every time I spend too much
time I don't react well but I I don't
even know what to do here because every
move I consider it just looked
terrifying after C4 is coming to C1 the
Knight going to B5 it just looks like
I'm just getting te made it no this is
not she just allowed me so much once I
get the pawn to G4 Knight on F5 she just
gave me everything it was this moment
that she had the move B6 did you see
spot this move during the game I mean I
spotted the idea I knew something like
this was coming but I thought okay I'm
going I have to take probably right and
then then attack me if you succeed you
succeed what can I do yeah yeah
absolutely and then she gave you this
opportunity night F5 now you're starting
to feel better about your attack right
you're getting some moves with Tempo in
was that your feeling as
well well I was feeling better about not
getting mated because now things really
can get on the light squares so okay I
have a bishop um covering the dark
Square so I'm blocking Bishop F3 Queen
goes to E4 B7 is covered I was really
shocked when she took on G4 because why
give me this open H
file yeah I mean here I'm already here I
was actually very happy already here I
could already feel things are going my
way because she just completely lost um
any threat of the position so I I
already could tell that something bad is
about to happen to her and then she
played this move Queen to E4 and that's
exactly the bad thing that happened to
her because you immediately uh blasted
open the position with the move D3 and
this is perhaps something that she
missed when did you spot this idea of
Rook to D4 after Rook D
C5 um when she went even before she went
Queen E4 because my whole game my whole
uh plan is associated with this D3 move
right get getting D3 open this diagonal
getting G3 somehow get some like make
the thing make the game messy right so
as long as I can get D3 my Rook comes to
D4 like I was kind of shocked I was like
am I winning here like how could this be
but uh you know now all a sudden I have
a pent need too t congratulations a big
important Victory bounce back Victory
after as you mentioned yesterday's
disappointment you're back in this
tournament you're for the moment a part
of the co leading group as you enter the
resty what are you going to do during
the
resty um well we have community service
to do and besides that I don't really
have any plans just take it easy I know
I have a big match coming up against
Kissa I believe I'm playing White
against Carissa so that's going to be a
huge match I probably spend most of it
preparing we'll see you after tomorrow
enjoy your rest day tatv and uh again
update